as president biden's plans become more
and more radical and as andrew cuomo
goes down in flames the media
desperately keep the focus
right where they want it on donald trump
who hasn't been in office for a long
time
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me remind you you
want to keep your front door safe
there's a lot going on
at that front door you got a lot of
packages being dropped off maybe
visitors stopping by i've got three kids
that means that i have to keep an eye on
all three of them at all times and my
baby daughter has just now found the
stairs which is always a dangerous thing
that means
that i need more eyes than ever the good
news is i have ring devices all over my
place
this is why you should check out
ring.com with ring you can see and speak
to whoever is at your front door from
anywhere right on your phones you're
never going to miss a visitor whether
it's your neighbor your dinner or your
groceries you can keep those packages
and delivery safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell and if somebody stops by
something's going on
ring will let you know again i love
having that ring up video doorbell and
i've had to bring security cameras
around the house
as well which has saved my baby
daughter's life several times at this
point see and speak to whoever's at your
door from anywhere with those video
doorbells you can keep an eye
on every corner of your house with easy
to install indoor and outdoor cams
protect your whole home with ring alarm
it's a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself right now get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit at ringgit.com
it comes that ring video doorbell 3
and the chime pro it's the perfect way
to upgrade your front door and start
that ring experience go to ring.com
again that is ring.com
ben okay so there's actual news
happening in the world but
there's more important news than the
actual news and that is our journalism
media the hot sticky journalism getting
absolutely everywhere
our media are all over the biden
administration top to bottom
they are on it let me read you a
breaking headline from newsweek you
ready for this
joe biden playing as luigi wins in mario
kart race against granddaughter at camp
david
whoa nelly the journalism how did joe
biden relax during his first president's
day weekend as president i don't know
that was the question that was foremost
on my mind
in the middle of a global pandemic and
in the immediate aftermath of a failed
impeachment effort
and you know with an economic downturn
and maybe some foreign policy crises on
the horizon and
what i was really worried about was how
did joe biden spend president's day
weekend you know because i remember when
donald trump went golfing it was really
really
bad because people were dying man but
joe biden that guy was playing mario
kart and because he was playing mario
kart that means he's cool
during his weekend retreat at camp david
biden and his granddaughter naomi played
the racing video game
and he won boom mic drop
old man wins mario kart breaking news
naomi shared a video to instagram and
showed biden competing against her on
the arcade gpdx machines
complete with chairs and steering wheels
biden sat on the right is luigi
naomi's princess peach on the left game
rant noted despite not being at the same
gaming level as his granddaughter the
commander-in-chief
came out victorious naomi joked on her
instagram story secret service made an
exception and let him drive himself
a little rusty but he won barely biden
told reporters on friday that he and his
family
plan to relax during the long weekend
we're gonna be up at camp david for
valentine's day he said adding they plan
to just hang out with the family
and do what we always do wow i mean this
is this is the important stuff isn't it
i mean i remember every single day on
cnn people focusing in on that coveted
counter
in the uh left-hand side of the corner
and i remember that it was it was really
great
you know every single day it was why is
donald trump took a dump do you know how
many people died while he was taking a
dump today
it's incredible but joe biden let's be
real covete's over cove is over because
joe biden is president he has cured it
it's gone sure it's not gone and
everything's still shut down but
but he's cured it and he carry it cured
it while playing mario kart which just
shows how magical he is
and lest you think that i'm just picking
on newsweek cnn has a piece today from
kevin liptak
it is one million words long it's called
inside the new president's routine
oval office fires and early bedtimes so
basically
this is just an attempt to spin the fact
that joe biden is super old and goes to
sleep
right after the early bird dinner at 7
45 pm as
him being you know comfortable quote
he has expressed a preference for a fire
built in the oval office fireplace
and sometimes adds a log himself to keep
it going
his dogs two german shepherds called
major and champ sometimes join him
wow man of the people the man adds a log
to the fire himself
as opposed to others who would have
called in a full cadre of servants
to add a log to the fire joe biden is
such a man of the people that he gets up
moves three feet puts a log on the fire
sits down with his two magical dogs
and then goes to sleep at 7 30 p.m i i
got to tell you i'm very impressed with
this president
i don't even have to know what he's
doing all i know is that he beat his
granddaughter at mario kart
over at camp david and also that he adds
logs to the fire sometimes before
heading down to the denny's and then
going to sleep
it is really really exciting stuff
happening in our media
now there is some stuff that's actually
happening here like for example the
biden administration is an actual
governing administration
and i know that our media got
unbelievably lazy during the trump
administration see here's the truth they
like to portray themselves as the
bulldogs during the trump administration
they were not bulldogs they really were
not they spent every waking moment
focusing in on whatever dumb thing trump
tweeted that day
the amount of investigative journalism
that they did that was outside of like
the russia stuff which turned out to be
a giant nothing burger
outside of that the amount of actual
hardcore investigative journalism they
did
was relatively restricted because they
had the easiest newsbeat in the world
you wake up in the morning the
president's tweeting something you go
out and yell about it on tv you go to
the white house press briefing room yell
at kaylee mcinandy about it you go home
and then the rest of the media talks
about you talking about the president
tweeting something about you
right it's like the easiest beat in the
entire world and the truth is journalism
really died under barack obama because
the journalist declared that barack
obama was such
an unbelievable magical man that there
was no reason ever to even cover the
stuff that he was doing
in fact it was considered bad form to
cover the stuff that barack obama was
doing
all you were supposed to do is cover the
fact that he was the greatest human
being who had ever walked planet earth
because he was the first black president
of the united states this was historic
and this meant that there was no reason
to cover any of his scandals remember
his only scandal according to our
journalism experts was that he once wore
a tan suit to a press conference
okay and then they got to trump and then
it was like okay well we could do
investigative journalism
or alternatively what we could do is we
could mentally masturbate about russia
for like
four years and also we could tweet we
could write a lot about his tweets
and ask everybody you know what's great
journalism going and asking a random
republican congress person
from say new mexico about what trump
tweeted that day that counts as
journalism
in journalism in the world so now it's
biden and most of the journalism that's
going to be done
is going to be this sort of shoulder
massaging stuff politico
had a headline today i'm not kidding so
yesterday
i talked about the fact that there are
so
many members of the media who are
willing to overlook the fact
that the biden administration is
completely gaming the cdc when it comes
to school reopening
right the school reopening standards are
pretty clear they should be open
you know how to reopen schools open them
done
they're open magic when you're talking
about particularly about elementary
schools
the amount of of safety precautions that
need to be taken
are significantly lower than you're
talking about from middle or high school
and again the data show that schools are
not the chief
modes of transmission to people who then
die of covid
is increasingly true as the vaccines
start to roll out okay but here is how
politico
here's how politico is covering this so
the biden administration rolled out a
bunch of cdc standards that are
completely anti-science
they suggest that i kid you not some 99
of all school children in the united
states ought to be in hybrid or
at-home learning only at this point in
the pandemic
and which is nuts it's completely
anti-science there's no rationale for it
and rochelle willenski the head of the
cdc openly admitted that they created
these standards
specifically in order to please the
teachers unions so how do our media
cover this here is politico's headline
politico's headline is this gop tries to
weaponize pandemic exhausted parents
against biden
oh the story always and forever as my
friend andrew clavin has said when
republicans do something bad the
headline is republicans
did something bad when democrats do
something bad it's republicans weaponize
democrats doing something bad
that's not a headline you mean the gop
opposes the democrats and is going to
talk about them doing bad stuff
that's not a headline the headline is
are the democrats doing a bad and stupid
thing
our media are so in the tank for the
democrats it is beyond all recognition
but
of course we know this already we'll get
to more of this in just one second
because again
here is the dirty secret the dirty
secret that is not a secret at all is
that joe biden is radical that his
administration is radical and they are
pushing forward radical policy that even
they
cannot keep up with we'll get to this in
just one second first
let us talk about the fact now not a
great time to go to the auto parts store
in fact never is an excellent time
to go to the auto parts store why would
you wait in line and then when you get
to the front of the line they ask a
bunch of specific questions you don't
really know the answers to them you have
to run out to your card to check and
then you come back in
and then the guy behind the counter is
like yeah we don't have that part we're
ordering it online and then we're gonna
upcharge you
instead you could just use something
called the interwebs it's amazing it's a
magical place go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts let's say like
hypothetically
i mean i'm just coming up with this off
the top of my head because this is my
thing you happen to need a delphi fg
1456 fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store well at rock auto that cost
217 bucks rockauto.com it's a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years head on over to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds
of manufacturers you can do it quickly
you can do it inexpensively it's a lot
better than going to that auto parts
store go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you again
go to rockauto.com right now and write
shapiro in there hell did you hear about
us box so they know and we sent you okay
so what exactly is joe biden doing
well he's blowing out the budget again
1.9 trillion dollars in spending
is what he's aiming for right here now
the most
well accepted bipartisan estimates
suggest that the economic shortfall in
2021 due to covet
is more like 450 billion dollars even
that is probably too high given the fact
that most of these states should already
be open
florida never closed okay if you walk
around my new home state the best state
in america from where i sit because
hey the rest of you guys are getting hit
with chill florida it's like 80 degrees
outside it's pretty fantastic also it
happens to be a free state
where people can still go and do the
things they want to do and exercise
caution while doing it
i take my kids to the park it's fine i
take my kids to the store with me we put
on masks
it's fine florida's been doing this
right so its economy has not
been completely destroyed new york
continues to do it wrong they have the
worst hospitalization rates in the
nation
and their business has been completely
killed right well
now joe biden wants to try out a 1.9
trillion dollar spending package
which again according to best estimates
is four times too large
four times too large and includes a
bunch of crappy provisions
so there are a lot of economists and
they're saying um you know guys we
already before this package
have spent 102 percent of our gdp on
government spending this year which is
the worst government spending binge
since right after world war ii since
1946 since the decommissioning
of the military in world war ii okay so
we are spending way too much money and
joe biden wants to add on top of that
another 1.9 trillion dollars
which is nuts right according to the new
york times even the new york times is
like
well you know we might be spending too
much money here jim tankersley and
giannis mjalik say
presidents who find themselves digging
out of recessions have long heated the
warnings of inflation-obsessed
economists
see even they're they're like yeah you
know inflation might be a problem but
we'll pretend that those people are
crazy
who fear that acting aggressively to
stimulate a struggling economy will
bring a return to the monstrous price
increases that plagued the nation
in the 1970s now as president biden
presses ahead with plans for a 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus package
he and his top economic advisors are
brushing those warnings aside
as is the federal reserve under chair
jerome powell after years of dire
inflation predictions that failed to pan
out the people who run fiscal and
monetary policy in washington have
decided the risk of overheating the
economy
is much lower than the risk of failing
to heat it up enough first of all it's
not the job
of the government to heat or not heat
the economy
the economy is not an oven the economy
is
a bunch of consensual transactions
between free individuals you know how
the government can make the economy
better by getting out of the way of
those free individuals involving
themselves in transactions
you know how the government can make it
worse by creating vast regulatory
infrastructures that dissent
disincentivize investment that's why the
economy grew slowly under
obama i love the revisionist history
that the reason that obama's economy
sucked
is because obama didn't spend enough
money obama went to 4 trillion a year
and then he kept it at 4 trillion a year
the united states used to spend about 3
trillion a year in the federal budget
now we spend four trillion dollars a
year in the federal budget that has
never come down
since the beginning of 2009 and the idea
is we didn't spend enough money if only
we had spent more money
no the reason that the economy recovered
unbelievably slowly under barack obama
is because barack obama held back the
economy with a regulatory thicket it's
because business owners understood that
barack obama did not like them
and that barack obama thought that the
regulatory infrastructure was necessary
to hem them in
until they kept money on the sidelines
trillions of dollars were on the
sidelines a lot of that money was
getting put in the stock market
not a lot of that money was going to
building new businesses and then
trump came into office and the economy
started to do really really well
okay it started to do better than it was
under barack obama you could see it in
terms of the wage increases people
started hiring people started competing
in the marketplace
now you're going to see a slower
recovery not just because of covet but
because
you're going to see this regulatory
infrastructure come back and it doesn't
matter how much money you blow into the
system the way that
joe biden is doing right now what we
have is not
a lack of demand okay what we have is
well i mean we do have a lack of demand
but it's an artificially created lack of
demand
it is not a problem of people have a
bunch of money there they are not
willing to spend
and then so we need more money in the
system the problem right now is people
are afraid to go to the store because of
covid and when that ends the economy
will go back to normal and everybody
knows this but in the meantime joe biden
is using this as a lever in order to
push his favorite economic policies
nonetheless according to the new york
times we shouldn't worry about inflation
at all just dumping money into the
system has no impact according to the
new york times
democrats in the house plans to spend
this week finalizing biden's plan to
pump nearly two
trillion dollars into the economy
including direct checks to americans
and more generous unemployment benefits
with the aim of holding a floor vote as
early as next week
the senate is expected to quickly take
up their proposal as soon as it clears
the house in the hopes of sending a
final bill to biden's desk early next
month
fed officials have signaled they plan to
keep holding rates near zero and buying
government-backed debt at a brisk clip
to stock
growth so we're going to keep borrowing
money effectively speaking and pumping
money into the economy we're going to
keep that that fed rate at zero and
we're going to toss two trillion dollars
into the economy
okay this is a recipe for inflation the
only reason that inflation may not
happen right now is again because
demand is artificially suppressed but
when demand stops being suppressed
you're going to start seeing price
inflation at a fairly radical clip
the fed and the administration are
staying the course despite a growing
outcry from some economist across the
political spectrum
including lawrence summers a former
treasury secretary and top advisor
in the clinton and obama administrations
who say biden's plans could stir up a
whirlwind of rising prices
nobody better embodies the sudden break
from decades of worry over inflation
in washington and elite circles of
economics than janet yellen yellen spent
the bulk of her career fighting in a war
against inflation
but at a time when the american economy
remains 10 million jobs short of its
pre-pandemic levels
and millions of people face hunger and
eviction she appears ready to move on
yellen said i spent many years studying
inflation worrying about inflation we
face a huge economic challenge here and
tremendous suffering in the country
we have got to address that that's the
biggest risk the problem again
is not that people broadly speaking
need a giant infusion of cash right now
to spend the big problem right now
is that there is an artificial lack of
demand caused by coveted regulations
everyone knows this the economy was
doing great up until march then coveted
hit and the economy sucked
so what caused the recession okay this
is pretty obvious to everyone which is
why if you look at the unemployment rate
in states like north dakota which really
never shut down the unemployment rate by
state right now you can see which states
shut down and which states did not shut
down
here are these states that have very low
unemployment rates nebraska
which hasn't really shut down three
percent unemployment rate three
percent in december of 2020. south
dakota
three percent iowa three percent vermont
three percent utah
three point six percent kansas three
point eight percent alabama three point
nine percent
even states that have been hard hit but
didn't shut down their economy
right even states like texas which is
pretty hard hit has a 7.2 percent
unemployment okay when you look at
florida right florida never shut down
florida's been pretty hit hard
6.1 percent okay now let's look at the
states that were hit the hardest
california nine percent nine percent as
of december 2020. could that have to do
with the massive coveted regulations
they put in place
nobody could go to work how about new
york new york's been shut down for the
duration their unemployment rate has
been 8.2 percent
so which is i have a question is it
because we need
more government interventionism in
california and new york or less
government interventionism in california
and new york you won't know why business
has been leaving those places for places
like florida that is the reason why
okay meanwhile that giant 1.9 trillion
dollar spending package
that of course is exciting people like
bernie sanders so bernie sanders every
single one of bernie sanders tweets ever
is
somebody else that that bad thing should
not happen
and that is why you need this unrelated
program to solve the bad thing that
should not happen
here is the reality is life is filled
with death
that is bad therefore we should have
socialism you're like what the
what are you talking about dude let's go
back to eating that pudding
here's bernie sanders tweeting about the
15 minimum wage you want to talk about a
policy that is calibrated
to do the reverse of what you are
attending to attempting to do
so we are hearing right now that people
are lacking jobs right
people are missing jobs particularly
low-wage individuals
are lacking jobs right now those are the
people got hurt everybody was able to
work from home
and work on a computer all those people
are doing fine in fact many of those
people are doing great
right all those journalistic fellows
over at the new york times they're doing
amazing
they're stoking the flames of shut down
politics meanwhile
they're still doing fine they're just
getting the grubhub delivered to the
door as opposed to going to local bistro
that is the only thing that has changed
for them
meanwhile low-wage workers across
america can't go back to work because of
all the lockdown politics
and the solution for democrats is to
raise the minimum wage so as to throw
half of them out of work
so bernie sanders tweets out a 15
minimum wage is not a radical idea well
if bernie sanders says it's not radical
i take him at his word
he says what's radical is the fact that
millions of americans are forced to work
for starvation wages
while 650 billionaires became over one
trillion dollar riches during a global
pandemic
yes we must raise the minimum wage to a
living wage
okay i i have a i have a question about
i have several questions about this
um first of all you can't be forced to
work for starvation wages against the
13th amendment
if you're working for starvation wages
on a technical level you would be dead
right starvation wages presump
presumably
by the terminology itself means it is
not a living wage a living wage
what bernie sanders means and presumably
is that he wants a wage that is higher
okay
you want to wage the tire now here is
the problem by setting a 15
minimum wage what you are actually doing
is increasing the wage artificially
beyond the point of employability let's
say that there are two people who are
out of work one is a college graduate
one is a not college graduate
before maybe you hire the non-college
graduate because the college graduates
demanding too much money
now you got a 15 minimum wage which
means you got to pay 15 bucks either way
okay so who are you going to hire the
college graduate or the high school
graduate
minimum wages put the people who are
lower down on the economic spectrum out
of work
they make sure that people who maintain
their jobs make a little bit more money
but the people who don't get those jobs
their minimum wage is zero it is zero
because they don't have a job their
minimum wage is now zero
a point that thomas seoul has made over
and over again when you set a minimum
wage you're not actually setting a
minimum wage
you're setting a minimum wage of zero
for most of the people who are out of
work
and a minimum wage of say 15 for the
people who get to retain their jobs the
other thing that's going to happen
obviously
is that people are going to start
implementing technologies right now
there are many stores out there that are
thinking okay well it costs maybe a
thousand bucks to put in a machine
instead of spending a thousand bucks i
hire somebody at low wage teenager at
low wage who needs a job
and i do i have that person do the job
it's cheaper than putting in the
machinery
if you want to replace the entire
restaurant business with robots
this is a pretty good way to do it is to
raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks
you want to know why over the past
decade you have seen grocery stores they
now have self-checkout counters
the reason that you have grocery stores
with self-checkout counters is because
unionized labor drove up the price
of price of labor for people who do the
checkouts
so the stores were like okay well either
i could deal with this union or i could
just pay a machine
zero dollars i could just put the
machine right there
and then we're done you worry about the
cost of automation
automation becomes less expensive than
labor when you artificially raise the
price of labor everybody knows this by
the way
you know who knows the minimum wage is
kind of a problem there's this candidate
his name was bernie sanders according to
vox.com
in early june 2019 bernie sanders
traveled to walmart's annual shareholder
meeting to confront company executives
over their moral culpability for the low
incomes of many of the company's
employees
walmart is the largest private employer
in america and is owned by the walton
family the wealthiest family in the
united states sanders said and yet
despite the incredible wealth of its
owner walmart pays many of its employees
starvation wages wages that are so low
many of these employees are forced to
rely on government programs like food
stamps medicaid and public housing
here's a quick note there he's actually
got the he's actually got the um
chain of events backwards when you
create government incentive programs
that pay people what you end up doing is
artificially lowering the wages
because companies no longer have to pay
ten dollars an hour they know the
government's filling in five dollars an
hour so instead they pay the other five
dollars an hour
okay all of this is just basic logic but
here's the problem for bernie sanders
sanders's campaign paid many of its
staffers in the 2020 campaign
primarily in the traditionally low-paid
field department less than 15
per hour oh isn't that amazing
as per our usual arrangement folks on
the left they have a standard that they
wish that everybody else would have hold
but they have no interest in upholding
it
themselves in just a second we're going
to get to more radical policy from the
biden administration
that we should ignore because joe biden
is putting another fire on the log and
playing as luigi
which by the way is a form of cultural
appropriation as far as i am concerned
we'll get to more of this in a moment
first let us talk about something
awkward
of course i'm talking about erectile
dysfunction that's something nobody
really wants
to talk about if you got it and you're
suffering from it the tendency is to
just ignore it hope that it goes away
but the reality is you can get it solved
quickly and easily and discreetly with
my friends over at roman with roman you
can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate
roman will ship it to you with free
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward
simple and discreet getting started is
really easy just go to getroman.com
complete
an online visit ed used to be tough to
tackle now there is roman complete
then online visit today to connect with
a healthcare professional and take care
of it
go to getroman.com ben today if approved
you get 15 bucks off your first order of
ed treatment that is getroman.com
once more that is getroman.com and if
you are approved you get 15 bucks off
your first order of ed treatment if you
got a medical problem go get it solved
get roman.com slash ben
okay so meanwhile there is the race
policy that will undoubtedly follow this
administration we've already seen it
implemented at the local level
the biden administration has repeatedly
suggested that equity is to guide all of
its decisions as we have
talked about at length on this program
when folks on the left say equity they
do not mean equality
what they mean is that any program that
does not achieve
equal outcome on the basis of group any
program that does not achieve that is
considered racist and to be anti-racist
whenever you see somebody saying
i'm doing the work i've become an
anti-racist it doesn't mean i've become
a not racist
it means i have become a person who
wants to tear down all existing
structures of power
castigating them as systemically
discriminatory
right that's what it means so this is
the stuff that the biden administration
has been pushing they've been pushing it
in vaccine policy they've been pushing
an educational policy they've been
pushing an economic policy an
environmental policy they literally said
that ibrahim x kennedy's idea of how the
world should work is the way they are
going to govern
which is scary as all hell because first
of all in many cases it is violative of
the basic principle of the civil rights
act of 1965 which is that people ought
not be treated on the basis of group or
race they ought to be treated instead on
the basis of their individual identity
instead this is not what is happening
and we are seeing it crammed down
in our educational system primarily so
christopher ruffo
who writes for a city journal and he is
the director of a
of a group called discovery the center
on wealth and poverty
at discovery institute so he has been
keeping track
of the woke equity politics that is now
being
mainlined into our educational system so
take a take a gander at this
chris ruffo tweets out the principal of
east side community school in new york
sent white parents a tool for action it
tells them they must become
white traitors and then advocate for
full white abolition
okay this is nuts so let's take a look
at this for just a second because
while the while the biden administration
i keep mixing them up because this is
just obama administration part three
because the biden administration
has embraced the basic equity playbook
here
this is what they mean they haven't gone
all the way yet but they will don't
worry we're very very early on
so they have been distributing at the
school the eight white identities by a
person named barn or hess
and and the eight white identities
stretch from white supremacist in the
red
to white abolitionists in the green
they say there is a regime of whiteness
and there are action-oriented white
identities
people who identify with whiteness are
one of these it's about time we build an
ethnography of whiteness
since white people have been the ones
writing about and governing others
okay what the hell does any of that mean
well let's get a little more specific
here are the eight white identities
according to barn or hass
again this is being taught now at
schools in new york
and by the way at schools that are
liberal in la same kind of thing
you're gonna see this brought into
public education with a vengeance over
the course of the next few years okay
that's the prediction
here are the eight white identities
according to barnard has
he says one white supremacist right
these are the worst people and this is
what all of american society is
clearly marked white society that
preserves names and values
white superiority that makes it your
white supremacist okay second
white voyeurism wouldn't challenge a
white supremacist desires non-whiteness
because it's interesting and pleasurable
seeks to control the consumption and
appropriation of non-whiteness
fascination with culture example
consuming black culture without the
burden of blackness so if you listen to
rap but you're white
this means that you're probably a white
voyeurist you're a white voyeur
right you're not a white supremacist but
you're kind of white supremacist
adjacent
because you're like a white supremacist
and that you like all the structures of
power but you also like listening to rap
music
then there is white privilege maybe you
critique supremacy
but a deep investment in questions of
fairness and equality under
normalization of whiteness and the white
rule
sworn goal of diversity so now if you
say that you like diversity
but you also believe in things like
fairness and equality on an individual
level
this means that you are suffering from
white privilege because of course the
entire system
is white and so if you say that you want
everybody to be treated equally on an
individual level this means you're
upholding
a system that has been supremacist in
the past and its supremacists today so
you're actually just privileged
okay then fourth level this is all this
is all called crap by the way this is
just cultic nonsense
fourth level okay now we are rising so
we went from the worst and
we're moving toward the best get ready
for it gang fourth white benefit
you're sympathetic to a set of issues
but only privately you won't speak or
act in solidarity publicly because
benefiting through whiteness
in public some people of color are in
this category as well
so this would be like candice owens so
if you're a black person but
you don't speak in or act in solidarity
with
whiteness in public uh or against
whiteness in public this means that
you're a voip benefit actually
according to these folks candace is
probably a white supremacist maybe a
white voyeurist
same thing for shelby steele a white
benefit person is a person
who um is actually a black lives matter
sympathizer but doesn't speak out very
loudly about it then there's white
confessional
okay white confessional is some exposure
of whiteness takes place but as a way of
being accountable to people of color
after you're seeking validation from
people of color okay so this is all the
people who marched
in the black lives matter protests but
are white who posted a black square on
instagram
you're white confessional because you
can see your own whiteness
but you're only seeking validation from
people of color now you might think to
yourself okay like
that should be about as radical as it
gets here you're basically saying that
the system you're you're conceding all
the points don't worry there's more
white critical now we're getting to the
people who are reaching saintly levels
of anti-whiteness white critical you
take on board critiques of whiteness and
invest in exposing or marking
the white regime you refuse to be
complicit with the regime whiteness
speaking back to whiteness this is white
people telling other white people that
they are too white
because why do you make white white make
white white okay finally
you can be a white trader you actively
refuse complicity
you name what is going on your intention
is to subvert white authority and tell
the truth at whatever cost
you need them to dismantle institutions
and finally you're a white abolitionist
this is like the highest level
you have you've cleansed yourself of all
sin you have purged yourself your full
robin d'angelo
white abolitionist you change
institutions you dismantle whiteness
you don't allow whiteness to reassert
itself but by the way what's amazing
about this is that you're still the one
in power right you're the white person
who's in power
and you're acting on behalf of people of
color you are now a white abolitionist
okay this is the crap they are teaching
to school children it's racist nonsense
there should be lawsuits on the basis of
this but get ready this sort of stuff is
going to be mainlined into american
politics
because as soon as you start using the
term equity this is where it's going we
all know this is where it is going
we're gonna get to andrew cuomo on the
collapse of the democratic coveted
narrative in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact you're
spending a lot of time with screens
these days here's one of the problems if
you spend a lot of time
with screens it can affect your sleep
patterns it can affect your headaches it
can really have an impact
on your mental and bodily health like it
really is not great blue light is not
good
for your brain and that is why you need
felix gray glasses felix gray glasses
they filter 15 times more blue light
from screens
than other clear blue light lenses high
quality frame materials they make felix
gray durable super lightweight they can
be adjusted to fit the original optical
lenses relieve most eye strain symptoms
from daily screen time
and the more advanced sleep glasses
relieve serious daily eye strain that
are specially designed for late night
screen time to improve
your sleep i mean these felix square
glasses they're fantastic which is why i
wear them
when i am working because i spend an
awful lot of time in front of screens
myself
felix gray frames their hand finished
from italian acetate making them durable
lightweight and super comfortable
blue light lenses come standard starting
at 95 bucks or you can add your
prescription at checkout starting
at 145 bucks if you don't love your
glasses in the first 30 days their
in-house customer care team will take
care of exchanges and returns no hassle
no questions asked felix gray glass is
designed for the 21st century go to
felix grayglasses.com to shop for
glasses that work as hard
as you do that is f-e-l-i-x g-r-a-y
glasses dot com slash ben free shipping
free exchange's 30 day money back
guarantee
felix grayglasses.com all right we're
gonna get some more
in just one second first as you know
actress gina carano was recently
canceled
by lucasfilm and disney plus why for the
great crime of being a conservative it's
very obvious that that was the case the
hollywood reporter
said they'd been looking for months to
drop her because she was conservative
and then they found an excuse
and they dropped her by the way they
didn't even bother asking her for an
apology they just can't her now that
would have been a
normal story of hollywood cancellation
except for the fact that we here at the
daily wire we are dedicated to fighting
back against this crap in two ways one
we want to make entertainment that
competes with the big boys and two
we want to make sure that when people
who are conservative get cancelled there
is a home
for them which is why we announced a
movie deal with gina literally the day
after she was dumped by lucasfilm that's
correct she'll be developing
producing starring in an upcoming film
it's going to be released only
to you guys the daily wire members we've
all been saying it for a long time that
conservatives need to do more than
complaining and critiquing we need to
actually stop running away from the
culture where we need to engage well we
can only do that
with your membership we are really
excited to be announcing our new
partnership with gina
the woke mob thinks they're in control
they have another thing coming now
here's the thing again
disney is going to spend 8 billion
dollars per year on disney plus
per year we've got you so we need your
help
and making movies is really expensive
making culture is really expensive
getting into the culture war is really
expensive but
here's the thing they've left themselves
really vulnerable and the more they keep
canceling talented people the more we
are going to work with those talented
people go to dailywire.com
subscribe use codegina that's g-i-n-a to
get 25
off your membership today also gina
carrano will be joining us for the
sunday special this week i'm really
pumped about it i think
you are going to love it you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so again the reality here is that the
biden administration is pursuing radical
policy across
the board and i gotta say it is
incredible to see
how when a democrat is in power
everybody just sort of comes out of the
closet with their true agenda
here i'm speaking of dr anthony fauci
the greatest of all doctors except for
dr jill biden who indeed is is the most
wonderful of all doctors so dr anthony
fauci
and for months and months and months and
months he was supposedly the most
knowledgeable person in politics
completely apolitical
not political just speaking for the
science that's all he was he was captain
sure he was on the cover of intouch
magazine sure they were they were
creating votive candles
of dr anthony fauci and sure he's
flipped his mind about 83 times on
masking and not masking in schools and
not schools
and sure now he's come back and he's
like you know what we need a stimulus
package which is a perfectly politically
driven idea we need a stimulus package
in order to reopen schools by the way
you know how you know that's not true
because if you actually look at the
biden package this 1.9
trillion dollar package that they are
now pushing if you look at the funding
for schools
you will notice something very very
weird hey would you like to hear the
weird thing the weird thing
is here is the spending by year for the
schools you ready for the department of
education
for 2022 some 32
billion dollars for 2022 for 2023
32 billion dollars and for 2024 25
billion dollars now
um i have a question why do you need
that for pandemic relief
seriously um i i 2024
is like three years away by my
calculations and yeah you're talking
about spending 25 billion dollars on
pandemic relief in 2024. i have a
feeling this has nothing
whatsoever to do with covet relief
nonetheless now fauci is free
and so faji can be just as much of a
democrat as he wants to be so here is
anthony fauci saying
you know like what we need right now is
to keep the focus on trump that's the
really important thing
we won't keep the focus on any of the
incompetence among the democrats who are
actually in power
in most of the major institutions across
our nation let's keep the focus on trump
so here's anthony fauci talking about
how he was worried about catching covet
at the trump white house
you know he's not in the white house
anymore donald trump you know what's
irrelevant this
i think you'd have to be oblivious not
to consider the fact
that if you get infected that you are
already in a category of someone who has
a high risk of having a serious outcome
i didn't fixate on that but it was in
the back of my mind
because i had to be out there i mean
particularly when i was going to the
white house every day
when the white house was sort of a super
spreader
a location i mean that made me a little
bit nervous
well you know and there he's smiling at
this well you know it's good it's good
to have scientific sources like dr fauci
talking about this stuff by the way dr
fauci
the the all sacrificing dr fauci who by
the way has the highest salary of anyone
in the federal government apparently
he was awarded a one million dollar
prize for speaking truth to power
not kidding you according to the daily
wire on monday the nation's top
infectious disease official dr anthony
fauci
received a 1 million israeli prize
established by late italian israeli
philanthropist
dan david fauci was honored with the dan
david prize for his service in public
health and speaking truth to power
during the pandemic according to npr as
the covet-19 pandemic unraveled
fauci leveraged his considerable
communication skills to address people
gripped by fear and anxiety
and worked relentlessly to inform
individuals in the u.s and elsewhere
about the public health measures
essential for containing the pandemic's
spread
in addition he has been widely praised
for his courage in speaking truth to
power
in a highly charged political
environment speaking truth to power
oh that's what yeah that's what he's
doing right now when he you know just
starts repeating all of the democratic
talking points
about coven speaking of which you may
have noticed that andrew cuomo is
completely falling apart so there was a
bit of odd juxtaposition yesterday so
andrew cuomo over the last couple of
days was awarded an emmy
he's given a television emmy for his
massively incredible performance during
the coveted pandemic which has ended
with the second highest death per
million ratio in america and currently
the highest hospitalization rate
in the nation after he wrote a book
about his amazing leadership
a bunch of hollywood celebrities stopped
by to talk about this because when we're
talking about health
the people who know the most are
obviously celebrities so here is spike
lee and ben stiller and the rest of the
crowd praising andrew cuomo
to my governor the governor empire of
state
andrew cuomo congratulations andrew
much deserved founders award governor
andrew cuomo you are the man what i was
trying to think of
that's something that i could say to you
that would uh
be funny and so i called your brother
chris who could not understand why you
were getting an emmy since he's the one
on television
in the darkness of the pandemic billy
crystal your daily briefings
live from new york gave us hope gave us
clarity
gave us the truth and gave us something
that we were not getting from washington
leadership oh okay so um it's good all
the celebrities came out
and that same week like within 48 hours
it turns out that andrew cuomo not only
was was lying about how many
coveted patients had died in nursing
homes but that he was covering it up and
he was lying to his fellow democrats and
then
he did in one of his trademark press
conferences like these emmy award
award-winning press conferences right he
did one yesterday
in which he just lied blatantly but he
was very clear about lying
so i mean i guess there's that so here
is andrew cuomo talking about how honest
he was while he was lying to be clear
all the deaths in the nursing homes
and in the hospitals were always fully
publicly and accurately reported
the numbers were the numbers always
people did request information
beyond the place of death not just where
they
how many in a nursing home not just how
many in a hospital
okay um so we were always honest except
for the fact that we were lying
and by the way everybody on the right
knew he was lying since may everybody
this is well reported for well now about
what seven eight months
minimum nine months and now the media
are getting around reporting all of this
my my favorite part of this press
conference is where andrew cuomo says
that he accepts responsibility
for letting people think he did anything
wrong which is like the best apology
ever here is andrew cuomo
man this guy he is such a jerk he's and
you guys propped him up as a hero
let it be known for months and months
and months he was the hero the census
was the villain the sansa's actually ran
his state correctly
cuomo's run a state like a garbage heap
here is cuomo
man this guy the the balls on this guy
it's pretty incredible
you'd never knock down all these
conspiracy theories the political
conspiracy theories
because they generate 10 a day but we
should have done a better job
of providing as much information as we
could
as quickly as we could and
we should have done a better job on that
uh yes
and no excuses uh
i i accept responsibility
for that i accept responsibility
for letting people i think think i did
anything wrong whoops
he what an incredible incredible dude by
the way he then went on and he said
deaths in nursing homes were inevitable
inevitable right this guy this guy who
praised himself for his leadership he's
like yep
i let the olds die and you know what it
was going to happen anyway so whatever
man
i got an emmy kovid did not get into the
nursing homes
by people coming from hospitals
got into the nursing homes by staff
walking into the nursing home
when we didn't even know we had covert
staff walking into a nursing home even
though they were asymptomatic
because the national experts all told us
you could only spread covet if you had
symptoms
and they were wrong okay so um there
there's only one problem with this
it's possible that clover was present in
those facilities earlier also you know
the way that you get rid of covet by not
having the patients
be in contact with other olds in the in
the nursing homes
and then of course uh and andrew cuomo
suggested
that um if those old people were gonna
die they were just gonna die anyway you
know that's just the way it's gonna work
the truth is it was in the middle of a
terrible pandemic
the truth is covid attacks
senior citizens the truth is
with all we know people
still die in nursing homes today
people still die every day
we're testing the staff twice a week
there's no visitation
people still die okay yes how many would
be the question
people still die is not that you guys
you guys made that you guys made this
human being into your hero
that was you okay so here's the thing as
all this unspools
biden's crappy economic policies crappy
coveted policies crappy racial policies
andrew cuomo falls apart
the media are focused in on what matters
most donald trump
and they're not gonna let donald trump
go away they just won't now trump
probably doesn't want to go away
but here's the reality of the situation
donald trump is no longer president
he will not be relevant to the political
conversation for at least another couple
of years if he decides to launch
another campaign which frankly i don't
think he's going to do because if i were
him i'd be incredibly tired of this
wouldn't you
so trump is not the relevant political
figure at this point
where are the democrats putting their
chief focus they're putting their chief
focus exactly where you would think
they're putting their chief focus
directly on donald trump so they're
going to continue to drag this out
house speaker nancy pelosi is now
pushing for the creation of a special
panel
to investigate the january 6th
insurrection at the capitol a day after
several lawmakers called for a
bipartisan commission and report
similar to the one drafted in response
to the september 11th 2001 terrorist
attacks
pelosi said now as always security is
the order of the day
the security of our country the security
of our capital which is the temple of
our democracy the security of our
members
to protect our security our security our
security our next step will be to
establish an outside
independent 911 type commission to
investigate and report on the facts and
causes
relating to the january 6 2021 domestic
terrorist attack on the us capital
complex okay what do you think this is
what do you think like here's the thing
i have an idea let's say that you wanted
to do a full investigation of what
happened on january 6th
call witnesses and everything you could
have done that you know and then
maybe after that you could have had like
an impeachment charge because apparently
you can now bring impeachment after the
person's out of office
and you could have done that or you
could even have done that investigation
between the house impeachment charge
and the senate vote but you didn't do
any of that stuff you rushed it forward
for political purposes
and then you got it off the table for
political purposes and now you just want
to keep this hanging around for
political purposes
for years on end so you can keep
pretending that donald trump is the most
relevant person to the political
conversation you're seeing this in the
media today by the way
well you know this is still trump's
party it's trump's party okay
here's the deal the party is always the
party of the prior president until
precisely the moment it isn't that is
the way that politics works
the democratic party was the party of
barack obama until it was the party of
hillary clinton in 2016
until it was the party of joe biden now
the republican party was the party of
george w bush until it was the party of
mitt romney until it was the party of
donald trump this is the way
presidential politics works there are a
lot of people today being like well it's
a trump cult because you see all these
people who are condemning republicans
for voting against trump in this
impeachment trial
no trump is just taken as a litmus for
republican solidarity it's that simple
when you ask republicans about how they
feel about trump even those who are
pretty uncomfortable with a lot of stuff
that trump did even many of those people
are not like you know what
i think what would be great for the
party is to completely divide it down
the middle on the question of trump
because he's out of office
sounds like a great plan here's the
reality democrats need
the looming specter of trump in order to
justify all the radicalism they are now
pursuing
in order to justify the fact they are
bad at their jobs and they are pursuing
radical policy
and again the media are addicted to this
stuff because the media's ratings go
down when they don't talk about trump
if if they talked about joe biden's
budget or how joe biden likes to toss a
log on the fire and that was all they
were covering i think anybody would
click on politico
you think anybody would watch msnbc
obviously not
obviously not so the democrats are going
to continue to push this stuff forward
and not just that
they're going to push forward more
radical policy on the basis of trump
we have a democratic representative
named jacobs and she came out and she
said you know what we need
we need a truth commission yes a truth
and reconciliation commission like south
africa this is what she told
the the most reliable of reliable
sources brian stelter
we need a truth and reconciliation
commission in the united states which is
the most orwellian garbage i've heard
in at least 37 seconds so here she is
representative sarah jacobs from
california calling for a truth
commission
you know a truth commission a lot of
people will think of south africa
we've used them in countries around the
world and basically what it is is it's
uh communities all the way up to the
national level
having conversations about both the
glory and the glory of our history and
what happened
both throughout the history of our
country and leading up to and on january
6th
so that we can come to a common
narrative moving forward of what we want
our country to be
yeah that this is all great it's all
great and all they have to do the
democrats just keep shouting trump
because orange man will remain
bad and he'll remain the focus and the
locus of the entire democratic universe
until such time as he is no longer
convenient for those purposes meanwhile
while you and the media are distracted
out here with trump this with this other
hand
that is where they are pursuing their
radical policy making which again is
going to make the country worse in a
wide variety of ways but the media have
no interest
in that the misdirection is at hand the
democrats are engaging in it
every single day do not follow the
bouncing ball follow instead the actual
activity that is taking place
in the halls of government okay we're
gonna be back here today with an
additional hour of content
plus the matt walsh show is airing today
at 1 30 p.m eastern today matt will be
discussing a famous male youtuber who
appropriates womanhood by pretending to
be pregnant
good times good times matt always comes
up with the most interesting stories be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show